pluriel à chausser ses baskets pour
lutter contre le cancer du sein
une marche rose de 6 km organisée à
aubergenville samedi 10 octobre
objectif sensibiliser et créer un
mouvement solidaire face à la maladie un
sujet qui tient à coeur
il s'avère qu'il ya deux ans j'ai été
moi-même touchées par cette maladie
personnellement et beaucoup de personnes
dans mon entourage familial et amical
et donc c'était vraiment l'occasion
cette année de la mettre en place avant
le départ de la marche
un ruban rose géant a été réalisée avec
les participants
une action symbolique n'a mis en place
ce ruban géant humains ruban rose a été
pris en photo pour la symbolique
c'était une petite feuille rose qu'on
devait mettre au dessus de sa tête parce
que la photo a été prise
en hauteur donc par un drone 160
marcheuses et marcheurs étaient au
rendez vous pour cet événement solidaire
il était présent pour sensibiliser et
soutenir les personnes atteintes du
cancer gelée par expérience dans mon
entourage donc je pense que c'est
important de faire connaître cette
maladie un peu plus et d'en parler
surtout se faire dépister à j'ai eu le
cas aussi avec ma maman donc d'autres
personnes que je connais donc allez vous
faire dépister c'est le principal déjà
par solidarité puis parce que le cancer
a touché toutes les familles dont la
mienne
nous on va bien on a cette chance
mais d'autres ne l'ont pas donc donc on
est là on est là pour ça au total 1100
euros ont pu être récoltés en faveur de
la ligue contre le cancer